Welcome back to human emotion.
So we know that emotions are inherently social,
but what do we actually know about emotions in a social world?
How do emotions look in our everyday social exchanges and how do they underlie,
shape and change some of our most vital social bonds with other people?
So these are some of the questions that we're going to continue to really probe
and examined today.
And then today we'll be focusing on emotions in a social world,
part three,
and in particular delving into the realm of relationships.
And I'm particularly excited today to have a very special guest lecture on this
topic,
Professor Margaret Clark.
So as we get into this topic today,
we'll start with our special guest lecture followed by our takeaway questions
and expert interview.
So I'm very,
very delighted to now we starting with our guests lecture today.
We'll be having Dr. Margaret Clark and professor of psychology at Yale
University speaking with us today on how the relational context shapes our
emotional lives.
So welcome,
Margaret.
Thank you for being here today.
Okay.
What I want to talk about is how relational context shapes or our emotional
lives.
Um,
from my point of view as someone who studies relationships,
I'm often struck by how often we focus on emotions as individual affairs.
We know a lot about how people express emotion on their face.
Um,
what the physiological can competence of emotion or we know a lot about how
individuals try to regulate their own emotions.
And we actually less often than I think is ideal think about emotions in social
context.
But emotions aren't entirely internal affairs.
We feel our emotions and we used that information to regulate our behavior.
But emotion show on our faces bay,
you can hear them in our voices.
They show in our postures and in fact we often express what we're feeling to
other people.
We tell other people that were sad or happy or angry.
Um,
they communicate something about us to other people.
And the fact that emotion show allows them to serve several social functions.
I'm going to mention just a few,
um,
and but talk primarily about one.
So one function that emotion serve socially is called social referencing.
Um,
people often look at other people in social situations to determine how they
should feel in that social situation.
If we walk into a room and someone looks scared to death,
um,
we may use that to think about what we should feel.
If they're scared that something's going on,
maybe we should be scared to death to.
Um,
so social referencing is one function that emotion serve.
Another is social protection.
If someone comes toward us,
they're walking toward us and they're smiling,
that's a pretty good sign that the situation is safe,
they're friendly,
it's,
we can interact with them.
It's probably a good idea to interact with them.
If on the other hand,
they're very angry and they're coming at us,
um,
it might be a good idea to get out of the situation.
So those are two kinds of social functions,
but they're not the ones I'm going to really focus on today.
A third function they serve is actually,
um,
to help us take care of other people's needs.
Emotions very often convey information about the person's needs,
um,
who's expressing that emotion.
So if a person is fearful,
they may need help.
In getting out of a situation or taking care of getting rid of whatever's
causing them fear.
If they're happy,
that actually also a signal,
some information about them that's important.
If they're happy,
that signals to us that maybe they're enjoying how we're interacting with them.
Maybe they like being with us.
We should continue.
Um,
if they're happy and sitting alone doing something,
maybe we shouldn't bother them at all.
They're perfectly fine all by themselves.
So I'm particularly interested in how emotions signal our needs to other people.
And that's what I want to talk about today.
So our relational context shapes how we react to other people's emotions,
whether we respond to them with support or whether we'd rather not give them
support when they express emotion.
I think we all intuitively know this.
Um,
although there's very few studies on them.
So consider a parent interacting with the child.
This is actually a picture of my nephew interacting with his two year old child.
So it's fine for a two year old to express any emotion he feels like to his
parent.
In fact,
it's very important that the child does this,
especially before they're able to talk.
If a,
if a baby cries,
for instance,
the parent figures out,
that's a cue that the parents should figure out what's wrong and do something
about it.
They should take care of that child's needs.
If a child giggles and laughs when the parent is reading a book to them,
that is a pretty powerful fit.
A signal that whatever he's reading,
the is pos to the child and he should keep reading.
So in a pair of child relationship,
the child should be expressing emotion to the parent.
The parents should be responding to that emotion.
But what about the parent?
Um,
the situation is entirely different to the parent.
What if the parent happened to lose his job and is very upset?
Um,
that period should not express,
I think we all know this.
This parents should not express that emotion to the child.
Why?
Because that child can't assume responsibility for taking care of the parent.
And so it's actually inappropriate for the parent to express emotion to the
child.
What about friends?
Here's a picture of me sitting with some of my friends.
Um,
friends have a more equal relationship.
They're often responsive to one another's needs and it's totally appropriate for
friends to express emotion to each other and they often do it.
Um,
and,
and the person to whom you express the emotion often responds with care.
Um,
so we don't have to suppress our emotion with friends.
On the other hand,
what if we're in a business setting and we're with business partners here?
I think we all intuitively know that it's not terribly appropriate to express
lots of emotion.
Why is that?
I think we don't think about it much,
but I think the reason is the business partners are not responsible for the
other person's needs they're doing,
they're engaging in business because they care about their own needs.
They have what we call an exchange relationships with one another.
And you really don't want someone with whom you're be,
you're doing business expressing like lots of sadness about what happened at
home because you're really not responsible for that.
So I think we intuitively know relationships make a lot of difference.
Now,
long ago,
along with Judson Mills,
I distinguished between two types of relationships.
Um,
and more recently I've emphasized a quantitative dimension of one of them.
So the two types of relationships we talked about where exchange relationships
and communal relationships.
In exchange relationships,
you don't feel any special responsibility for the other person's needs.
You do exchange benefits,
but you give benefits to the other person with the expectation of receiving
something in return.
Um,
and when you accept a benefit,
you expect to repay the other person.
You have no special responsibility for their needs.
On the other hand,
in communal relationships,
you do feel a special responsibility for partners.
A communal relationships are often exemplified by friendships,
uh,
parent,
child relationships,
romantic relationships,
and these relationships you give benefits,
um,
to,
to support the other person's a welfare to,
to promote the other person's welfare and you do it non contingently.
Now unimportant,
a point about communal relationships is that there is a quantitative dimension
to them.
We don't assume an equal degree of responsibility for all our communal partner's
needs.
And I'm going to show that on the next slide.
Um,
what I have here,
what,
um,
actually I'm going to switch perspectives a little bit and I want you to
consider the responsibility that others assume for our welfare first.
So what I have here is something called communal strength.
And this is communal strength in terms of what we expect from a partner.
We don't expect much from an infant.
An infant has very little ability,
no ability really to take care of our needs.
And so we don't expect much communal behavior from an infant.
Um,
we actually expected a little bit more from an adult stranger who has some
capability in a stranger could give us directions or tell us a time.
And we expect most strangers will do that.
We assume more responsibility or for a friend.
Um,
we assume responsibility for ourselves.
and we also,
we may assume a great deal of responsibility for a romantic partner.
I don't want to suggest that everybody orders relationships in this way.
This is just one person's a set of relationships and the way one person might
order them.
Um,
the point is more that we do order our relationships,
uh,
in terms of how much responsiveness we expect from the other person.
So over on the y axis,
I have your perception of the other person's care.
So you could draw a line through this figure that depicts how much you expect
the other person to care for your needs.
You don't expect an infant to care much.
You expect to read a real romantic partner to care a lot.
So beneath the line we expect care from the other person and above the line we
do not expect a care.
So I haven't talked about emotions yet.
What does all this have to do with emotions?
Well,
um,
I think below the line,
you,
they,
they're supposed to provide care and our emotions suggest,
uh,
what they need to do above the line.
We don't expect care.
And if we express our emotions,
they might even exploit those.
So I would say you should express emotions indicative of needs beneath the line.
Not all emotions express needs.
So things like fear,
sadness,
and happiness,
you should express,
uh,
in this domain.
Um,
and above the line actually you should suppress the emotion.
You should suppress the emotion for couple of different reasons.
Um,
one is that the other,
it'll be annoying to other people.
They don't want to assume responsibility for your emotions and for taking care
of you.
And the other reason is they could use that information against you.
They could actually exploit you.
So,
um,
consider looking for a house and relater is showing you around and you find the
house you love.
You don't want to express too much happiness because the realtor's not
responsible for your needs and they could use that happiness against you.
They could use that as a signal that they could suggest the higher price to you.
So you might want to suppress emotion and that case.
So,
um,
here's the first proposition I have.
People should express more emotion,
the greater the perceived strength of their communal relationship.
And I'm going to show you a couple simple studies that tests this proposition.
Um,
the first one was one that I did with Julie Fitness and Ian percent and it was a
simple self report study.
Um,
we ask people to consider a number of different relationships and we asked them
how communal their relationship was,
how strong it was,
and we asked them also in a separate set of [inaudible] to tell us the extent to
which they express each have a number of emotions to that particular partner.
Would you express anger,
disgust,
fear,
hurt,
sadness,
contentment and happiness.
Um,
these are the 42 people,
um,
that we have,
I shouldn't say that.
42 people rated the communal strength of their relationships with a number of
different people,
a stranger,
their mother,
a casual friend and so forth.
A fellow employee,
we did not assume that everybody had every kind of relationship.
If you weren't an employee,
uh,
you wouldn't answer about a fellow employee you just answered for every
relationship you had.
And this is how we measured communal strength.
There's a standard scale to measure how much responsibility,
um,
you feel for another person or them for you.
Here it's how much responsibility you feel for another person.
Um,
but in this case,
we flip these items to be how much you think they,
uh,
responsibility they assume for you.
And then,
um,
people rated the extent to which they would suppress or express different
emotions to each person from definitely they would suppress it to definitely
they would express it.
And here are the results.
These are,
these are just the average correlations between communal strength and
willingness to express them all.
Each of these emotions for the individuals in the study.
And what you can see is they're all positive correlations.
The more communal the relationship,
the more you expected,
the other person felt responsibility for you.
The more you expressed each of the emotions we ask about negative and positive
and all those correlations are significant.
Now this was at we,
we ask,
there's another part to this study I need to explain.
We ask about expressing it when the cause of the emotion was your partner and
you express it.
We also ask,
uh,
about what happens when it was caused by someone else,
something or someone else.
Um,
and you also see that the correlations are positive.
so the overall takeaway from this,
a simple study is that just that a more communal a relationship is the more of
the communal strength,
the more you'll express emotion.
Now I want to focus on something else here.
There's one odd thing you might have noticed and that's that for anger and
disgust,
the correlations are lower than for the other emotions when they're caused by
your partner.
And that I think is understandable because these two emotions do convey
something about your needs.
If,
if I'm angry at you,
you should do something to decrease my anger.
I want you to do something.
On the other hand,
if I express anger to you,
it hurts you.
It might hurt you if you did something disgusting and I say you just did
something disgusting.
Um,
it,
I might want you to stop eating with your mouth open.
I'm,
on the other hand,
I might hurt your feelings by expressing it.
So because these two,
if you express it might hurt your partner.
I think it's stamped down a bit,
but you have no problem if someone else made you angry or someone you found
disgusting expressing it to your partner.
And that's cause I think it,
it doesn't hurt the person you're expressing it too.
But it is striking that all the correlations are positive.
Now let me tell you about another study.
The tests,
the same idea.
This is a study of marriages involving both husbands and wives.
We had 108 married couples,
uh,
and we,
we ask them in self reports to tell us the extent to which their spouse followed
the communal norms.
So now how responsible is your spouse for your welfare?
They're all marriages.
So there's an important point to make about this,
that even within one type of relationship and this case marriage,
a communal strength varies.
So marriage is or ordinarily communal in nature,
but they vary in communal strength.
We also asked the extent to which these,
um,
each of the spouses expressed fear,
sadness,
and happiness to each other.
Um,
and the extent to which they express these emotions to other.
Now we're asking about the marriage.
Um,
so we expect that to correlate with how much you express emotion to your spouse.
because it's about the marriage per se.
We don't think it will have anything to do with whether you express the emotions
to other people.
So it's not that they are very communal people who express emotion to everybody.
It's the,
that matters.
It's,
it's that their communal relationships,
um,
that matters.
So here's what we got for predicting emotion expression from perception of one
spouse following communal norms.
So you see that the,
um,
the more communal the relationship,
the stronger it is.
The more people expressed fear,
sadness,
and happiness,
but it didn't have any impact on how much they expressed to other people.
Okay.
So what if talked about so far is how believing that other people care about
your welfare influences your tendency to express emotion to them.
But there's another side of the picture.
Um,
and I tried to capture that in the second proposition.
Uh,
we think that people should react more positively to partner expressions of
emotion.
The greater the perceived strength of the community relationship.
So here what we're concerned about is your care for the other,
that we're now flipping the perspective and we're saying the more you care for
the other,
um,
the more emotion you should express.
Again,
you can draw the line.
I'm here.
Notice something about this graph.
I've moved the infant from the low end to the high end because we tend to care a
lot about infants and feel responsible for them.
We think it's fine for them to express emotion.
So some relationships,
community relationships are symmetrical like friends and romantic partners,
but some are asymmetrical like infants.
So,
um,
we feel a great deal of responsibility for them,
but don't expect them to feel responsible for us.
That's why I think it's appropriate for infants to express their emotion to us,
but it's not appropriate for us to express too much emotion to the infants.
So,
um,
this is just looking at others care for you.
Um,
underneath the line you should prepare,
provide care for the other person above the line.
No care is required.
You should respond positively to express emotion indicative of needs.
I don't want to say it's every possible emotion,
but emotions a indicative of need,
like fear and sadness.
You should respond positively to and above the line.
No responsiveness is required from you.
Indeed.
You may be annoyed if the other person express their emotion.
So if you employ,
say,
um,
uh,
administrative assistant in your office and that person expresses,
you know,
every emotion they feel in their life,
it's not going to make the relationship good.
It's going to hurt the relationship.
People will be annoyed.
Okay.
So now I'm going to continue talking about my marriage study and tell you about
another thing that emerged from it that has to do with perceiving,
I think perceiving other people's emotions and how you react to it.
So it's the same study with the same 108 couples.
Um,
and I want to,
these are the things I already told you about,
uh,
measuring,
but we also measured how satisfied people were with their marriage.
So,
um,
what we found that I think is pretty interesting is that males reports of
expressing emotion.
So what the male said,
did they express sadness that they express happiness,
they express fear is with,
um,
was related to their wives,
independent reports of marital satisfaction.
Um,
the more the male's expressed emotion,
the more satisfied their wives.
Where would the relationship,
and what I think this is about is they're willing to tell their wives about
their vulnerabilities.
They're willing to ask for support from their wives,
their wives,
they're able to get it and the wives end up more satisfied.
So here's a positive reaction to another person's expression of emotion.
Um,
let me go back a bit.
I'm going ahead too quickly.
Um,
I should say that we did not get the parallel effect for wives,
but I don't think that's because the same effect doesn't apply to wives.
Instead,
what we found,
which was interesting is that the wives all expressed emotion.
And so there was very little variability in weather wives expressed emotion.
And because of that,
we couldn't observe a correlation between,
um,
wives expression of emotion and their husbands satisfaction.
So I don't think it doesn't apply to wives,
it's just that uh,
women express more emotion than do men.
And now let me tell you about another study that looks at how we react to other
people's emotions depending upon our relationship with them.
This is a truly experimental study and what we did was we looked at,
we brought people into the lab and instead of looking at existing relationships,
what we did was we looked at,
we manipulated desire for communal or an exchange relationship with the other
person.
And we did it in a very simple way.
We had college students participate in the study.
It was supposedly on impression formation.
They expected to meet another person,
but before they met the person,
they were going to exchange questionnaires,
a form,
a first impression,
and then they expect it to actually talk with the other person.
And we did something very simple.
We thought most new freshman college students are anxious to meet new people,
maybe to form friendships,
maybe to form a romantic relationship.
And so if the other person is attractive and friendly and we made the other
person attractive and friendly,
we thought they'd naturally be open to a communal relationship.
But then we wanted to do that in.
And the other,
uh,
in the other condition we had the same attractive,
friendly person,
but this other person said that they'd signed up for the experiment because they
were very busy,
uh,
and their husband or wife had to pick them up afterwards.
Um,
what this communicates immediately is that this is probably not a candidate for
a friendship or romantic relationship.
This person is different from the average college student and we expected they'd
prefer an exchange relationship.
Simple manipulation.
Um,
now in the study,
what happened was they filled out questionnaires and one of the question you
were asked how they were feeling right then and the other person says,
I'm not feeling any particular emotion or I'm feeling happy or I'm feeling mad
or I'm feeling fearful or anxious.
I forget exactly what it is actually.
Um,
let me first show you what happens when they express no emotion.
Here's liking over here.
Um,
communal relationships are depicted in blue exchange and red.
and they liked the two people equally.
Well.
There's nothing wrong with the married,
busy person.
You don't expect a communal relationship.
Um,
but there's nothing wrong with them.
They're perfectly likable as he is the available person.
That was actually luck,
uh,
in the study that they came out exactly the same.
Um,
now I'm gonna switch this graph.
So this is going to be the baseline now.
And what I'm going to do is show the deviations caused by sadness,
anger,
and happiness.
And I said that was,
um,
maybe anxiety.
It was happiness.
So,
um,
here's what happens with sadness.
Here's the baseline.
They like each other.
God are the same.
Uh,
and what you see is when someone expresses sadness in the communal condition,
it actually increases liking a bit.
Why would that be?
I think it provides an opportunity to be responsive to the other person.
It's actually kind of Nice when someone's willing to express their sadness to
you.
But look what happens in the exchange,
uh,
condition you really liking for the other person drops.
You don't want to be responsible for that knee,
that person's need.
And now we're going to look at anger.
So one lesson,
there's a main effect here and we don't like angry people,
but it actually doesn't significantly decreased liking for the community and the
communal condition.
It doesn't exchange.
We don't want to be around angry people are not.
Everything is explained by whether a relationship is communal or not.
It's unpleasant to be around angry people,
but it's more appropriate I think to express it and communal and it decreases,
um,
liking less there.
And finally,
let's look at happiness.
There's another main effect here.
We like happy people.
I think that's not surprising at all.
Um,
but it increases our liking for a communal partner much more than an exchange
partner.
And the overall lesson from this study I think is it's more appropriate to
express emotion in communal than an exchange relationships.
Um,
and we like,
it affects liking,
um,
more in a communal,
whoa.
Not more,
but it affects,
it affects liking in different ways in these two relationships.
Um,
it's,
it just,
you know,
more appropriate.
We'd like people more who express emotion.
Um,
if we have a commute we expect to communal and an exchange relationship.
Okay.
And now what about behavior?
How do we behave toward people who express emotion?
So we looked at this and yet another study.
It's a fairly old study.
Um,
but we made a simple prediction that will respond to people with whom we expect
a communal relationship.
And we manipulated it in the same way.
And this study will respond to uh,
a communal partners.
Sadness with increased,
helping well help a communal partner more than an exchange partner in the first
place.
But then we'll respond to sadness more positively.
But what if an exchange partner expresses sadness?
We predicted that we wouldn't react positively to their expression of emotion.
It was fairly elaborate study.
Um,
and I won't go into all the details,
but we brought people into the lab to people participating at the same time.
One was a confederate.
They had to do an art project.
One person had to paint a painting,
the other person had to make a balloon sculpture.
And we said,
we were interested in the effects of mood.
On performance on these artistic tests.
So they rated their mood,
um,
and the,
the confederate actually did it,
um,
after,
the actual participant and then the confederate said they had to leave the room
for a little bit.
Um,
so that left the real participant alone with the confederates questionnaire and
everybody did exactly what we hoped,
which they looked at it and they could see that the other person was sad or not.
The experimenter comes in and looks around and says,
well,
you can just paint you're painting if you want,
or,
you know,
I forgot to blow up the person's balloons for the balloon sculpture and I don't
have time to do it.
The experimenter was great and terribly disorganized,
um,
and said,
you can help them blow up the balloons if you want.
You don't have to.
You could just do your painting.
And the,
and then the experimenter leaves and we looked,
we wanted to count how many balloons they blew up for the other person.
But we had unfortunately purchase balloons that were impossible to blow up.
So we changed our manager to how long they tried to blow up the balloons.
Um,
and I want to show you the results,
um,
which are here.
So this is how many seconds say spent trying to blow up the balloons.
This is the other person's mood.
They were either sad or they were in a neutral mood.
Um,
and what you can see immediately is in the communal condition,
they help more.
So that's not a surprise.
Uh,
lots of,
I think people help to form relationships lots of time.
What's important here is that sadness increased,
helping in the communal condition,
um,
and it had no effect and the exchange condition.
Now I actually think if we weren't at rock bottom and helping here that we might
have found that sadness decreased helping that you want to get out of there.
You don't want to help the sad person,
but in fact,
um,
we had a floor effect so we couldn't observe that.
Okay,
here's the proposition three,
and this is the last one I'll talk about.
We think that expressing emotions should help us to build close communal
relationships.
And,
uh,
this,
we did study five,
I didn't put the reference up and I should say that this was a study done by
Steve Graham,
um,
at Carnegie Mellon University.
And what we did is we contacted freshmen before they came to college and we
asked them if they'd participate in this study.
We measured their willingness to express for emotions and then we collected some
demographic measure itself self as a measure of self esteem.
Here's how we measured willingness to express emotion.
We just ask how willing are you to express fears,
annoyance,
anger,
sadness,
and anxieties to other people?
And they answered that.
Now it's important,
I think that implicit in this is how willing are you to do this when it's
appropriate?
So we asked that,
uh,
and we predicted that students willing to express the four emotions,
negative emotions would be more able than others to form.
Many friendships are establishing intimacy in the closest of those relationships
and have partners who were responsive to them.
So this is interesting.
Uh,
the papers actually called the positives of negative emotion because we think
that expressing negative emotion gives your partner an opportunity to be
responsive.
Um,
so they filled out our emotion majors,
a ride to school and all we did was wait until the end of the first semester to
collect our measures.
At the end of the semester,
we ask how many friendships they had.
We measured that in two.
We just outright ask them,
how many friends do you have but you didn't have before you started college?
Um,
we also,
because we thought people might not be honest about that,
we asked them to give us the initials of people that they ate breakfast with
lunch with and dinner with.
So they had to think in concrete terms.
Who do I actually spend time with?
Both those measures showed the same thing.
We measured intimacy and the two closest friendships.
So how do we measure intimacy?
Are we ask if the,
if the person's,
um,
seem to understand that?
I think if you express your emotions,
they're going to understand you better.
Um,
does the person,
except you were optimistic.
We think that people respond to other people's negative emotions positively when
they're forming friendships.
And we ask is the person caring because we thought if in fact you express
negative emotion,
you're giving the person a chance to care.
And what we found was that willingness to express negative emotion,
what one's negative motions were the significant and positive predictors of the
number of friends they reported having and the intimacy in the two closest
friendships.
But then we had a fortunate thing happen.
There was another researcher at the same university studying these same freshmen
and she happened to have,
this was Vicki Helgeson.
She happened to have majors from,
we had 38 people for whom she had measures from their roommates of how much
support they had given to the roommates.
She was interested in social support.
So we could combine those data sets and look at whether the are people who said
they were willing to express negative emotion,
got support from their roommates.
And what we found was that,
um,
willingness to express negative emotion was a significant predictor of
roommates,
independent reports of having given them help collected by an entirely different
researcher doing an entirely different study.
So,
so we think that expressing emotions does help you to build,
um,
communal relationships.
So,
um,
let me sum up now in,
I,
I strongly feel that relationship context shapes are expressions of emotion and
they also another,
our expression of emotion in turn shapes our relationships and allows us to grow
relationships.
Um,
and it leads to a somewhat surprising prediction that expressing negative
emotions is a positive thing and helps you to grow relationships.
Although I've emphasized,
um,
expressing emotion.
I want to make a couple more comments about how relational context and
particularly communal relational context shapes people's emotional lives.
I suspect it's not all about expressing emotion or receiving support because,
um,
when you express emotion that also influences your of emotion.
So we know from lots of studies of emotion that facial feedback,
um,
influences our emotions.
We know that when,
um,
we,
we actually sometimes I'm in manipulating emotions by telling people to recall
cases where they experienced a particular emotion.
So if you were in fact doing this with our partners,
I think we're influencing not only expressions of emotion and receiving help,
we going floating our experience of emotion as well.
Now,
I'm not sure exactly how that works out across,
um,
situations where we're suppressing emotion versus expressing it.
But I think it's an interesting direction in which to go.
And the other point I'd like to make is that I think this work strongly suggests
that regulation of emotion,
which is normally studied as an individual thing.
Um,
there are lots of studies on regulation and emotion.
It's normally studied in a single person and how they're regulating their own
emotions.
But I strongly feel that emotion regulation is often a social affair.
We often cheer up our friends.
We often empathize with our friends.
Um,
we distract our friends and we sometimes reappraise our,
uh,
partners state,
for their benefit.
So they think it's the worst thing that happened,
is the worst thing in the world.
And we may as their partner reframe that for it for them.
I think that happens a lot.
So another interesting direction,
um,
that we're going in is to look at how relational context shapes regulation of
emotion.
So although today I've emphasized expression of emotion and being responsive to
other people,
I also think this has a lot to do.
Relational context has a lot to do with experience of emotion and also with
emotional regulation.
So I thank you.
Yeah.
So thank you very much,
Margaret Clark for a fantastic guest lecture.
I'd now like to turn to our takeaway questions to sort of glean what were the
main important themes for the guest lecture you heard today.
So our takeaway questions today will go as follows.
First,
why is it important to consider emotional lives in a relational context?
In the lecture you heard today?
Second,
what are the differences between felt emotions on the one hand and expressed
emotions on the other?
And finally,
how do relationships vary in the extent to which a partner assumes
responsibility for another as welfare?
And now I'd like to turn to our expert interview as part of the experts in
emotion interview series
are experts and emotion interview will be with Dr. Margaret Clark on emotions
and relationships.
So Dr. Clark is a world renowned expert in close relationships,
both friendships and romantic relationships and emotions,
and in particular the ways people experience and express emotions within
relationships among her various distinctions.
Dr. Clark is one of the founders and former presidents of the society for
personality and social psychologist.
She has countless books and publications and has received numerous awards and
recognition of her accomplishments.
So I now turn to a very special experts and emotion interview with Dr. Margaret
Clark on emotions and relationships.